we are excited to introduce you to our
homies logic training programs in
nigeria
this program will help you see the role
of big data our next generation
technologies in life sciences homies
logic bio forensics training
is designed for everyone interested to
learn and apply data science skills
to study biological data sets in an
effective and meaningful way
however before we get started let me
introduce you to our computer vision
continue
my name is aditya abushady and i'm the
community manager of comics logic
nigeria i'm responsible for daily
interaction
with thousands of users that are part of
our bioinformatics community
managed by prime biotech let me start by
introducing time about
the company behind once logic i'll also
share with you details about the
upcoming obstacle programs
and explain how the training resources
we'll discuss today
will be used in upcoming data science
training
program
kindly and join all participants to meet
themselves so that will not be disturbed
by
the noise coming in from their
individual phones
the omics logic is a program for
mathematics training
that was developed in collaboration
between primal tech
and the turban informative research
center what we would discuss today
on chinese program is a result of
artwork by an amazing
film led by the company co-founders
doctor alfred tubber and dr leonid
grotzky
dr alfred tubber who comes from a
medical background
has extensive expertise in oncology
immunology
and biochemistry of inflammation has
been recognized
internationally for his generous support
of many research projects and
initiatives that support
data science training and applications
in medicine
dr leonid is the director of the tobac
informative research center
at university of afa and is an expert in
bioinformatics and biostatistics
he has been known as publications in
mathematics and bioinformatics
and over the course of his career has
developed multiple
novel golden approaches to biomedical
data analysis
the rest of the team includes experts in
bioinformatics
computer science and training and some
of them will be presenting
today as well over the course of the
past several years
collaborating with the number of
academic institutions around the world
that have participated in content
evaluation
as a result of this the omics logic
programs have been totally evaluated
and are known to lead to excellent
outcomes importantly
the programs are designed to support
students
with minimal bioinformatics background
including biology
and biomedical studies majors as well as
faculty interested in informatics data
science and
medical research
the goal of homicides programs is first
to provide training in bioinformatics
enabling independent research guided by
mentors and paid examples
developing a growing community with
shared passion for data-driven research
and appreciation of life sciences
enabling students
clinicians and faculty of all
backgrounds
to develop novel and independent
research
using the latest technology in life and
data sciences
in this webinar our team introduce you
to resources
i get you started on this journey we
hope that you'll be able to benefit
from this webinar the objective
so let's go to our educational resource
platform which is
edut build.info and
get signed up please
mr nuclear can help me put
the website
into the chat phone edu dot
t iphone bio dot info
are we out there
yes we have uh bipsa
biswas who is able to put the link in
the chat
and we have also adekunle and hamsa
that also are able to do that so please
someone
please help adata get the link in the
chat
so for the new users
you have to register or sign up
there there's an option
right where i put this black box which
is another member sign up if i knew
users i would not be introduced to the
website
this is where you go you click the
register now button
and you bring out these options where
you have to input your name your
password
they also have to click the i'm not a
robot capture
where you submit and it takes you
directly to the website
maybe after that
anyone had anybody is there anybody that
have
problems with signing up or logging in
it doesn't look like anyone is having
any issues
okay then so in case there are any
issues you can put it in the chat box
and
will attend to you completely so moving
on
we're excited that this event has been
led organized by education in
engineering
it has brought together experts who have
an interest in data driven research
and have all recently completed our
specialized training
they're now certified and ready to
assist all of you enjoy this program
getting registered and finding all of
the necessary resources
and helping you troubleshoot any
technical or conceptual challenges you
may come across
uh faculty and agile because
comprises mistakes anyway myself
and mr sunny hamza and this
faculty was supported by our team in the
u.s and india
we have dr opted at the topic called
a certified old study trainer and expert
organization
who guide the hands-on sessions and
assist the participants with projects
and analysis during the program our area
of specialization
is cancer genomics and machine learning
we also have dr mohit mazonda
omix logic project mentor and expert
in big data commercial analysis with dr
mazunder as a phd
in commissioner biology and over 10
years of experience working with
industry and academia
we also have elia brodsky prime bounty
co-founder and ceo
in his current role he has extensive
experience working together with
industry and academic partners
that are applying multi-comics
integration
and bioinformatics to a variety of about
technology and clinical applications
i will now pass it on to you to talk
about the increasing significance of
data science and biomedical research
and introduce you all to the types of
challenges we'll be addressing
in this upcoming program over to you
thank you very much and welcome everyone
to
this webinar so as uh
adataio mentions i am one of the
co-founders
and currently the ceo of pine biotech
and as a result of uh
being in this role i have gotten
a lot of experience interacting with
participants of different training
programs
as well as researchers from around the
world that are using a lot of our
infrastructure to help them manage
and analyze big data so this webinar is
the second webinar the first one that we
held
a few days ago was dedicated to the very
first introduction of the different
resources
and the topics that we will cover in
this upcoming
basic ominous logic training program for
nigerian participants
what we asked all of you to do last time
is
also to get signed up to make sure that
you understand how the materials are
organized and so we were excited to see
that many of you have also completed
your profile
started learning by taking some of the
coursework that we asked you to complete
and you probably noticed that you have
points for completing
different types of courses and
activities
you also have an indicator on your
profile page of how much of your program
of your course you have completed
and also you have a certificate that
comes with many of the courses that we
have available
so that's what we did last time we also
asked many of you
about your educational qualifications
we saw that the majority are master
degree students
and the second bigger category is
bachelors or undergraduate students we
also asked about research
interests and we noticed that many of
you were interested
in basics
diseases and precision medicine and
we also asked about what type of omics
technology you're interested in and it
looks like the majority are interested
in genomics and typically
that happens because many people are
much more familiar with the topic of
genomics and with the term genomics
rather than some of the additional omics
data types like transcriptomics and
metagenomics
so this is some indication for us that
helped us shape today's presentation
and talk about the different
technologies and how do they
all combine together to illustrate how
we can study
different types of biological phenomena
using bioinformatics
so what is covered in this introduction
to bioinformatics core
of course the introduction to
bioinformatics is just one of the
introductory courses that we have
and it introduces participants to
different applications
of bioinformatics and what
bioinformatics is
but we also have these introductory
courses for different types of omics
data
and we've seen in our previous programs
that many of the participants are highly
raking
these resources that are intended for
asynchronous
independent learning let's talk about
what bioinformatics is and how is it
related
to what we will cover in the overall
training program
if you could please help me by yes
keeping it quiet thank you
bioinformatics is the intersection of
informatics statistics and biology
it's like a specialization of
information technology
and statistical analysis for biological
data and biological problems
and this includes a variety of different
skill sets
that we try to cover in our introductory
program
to get everyone on the same page and
provide a perspective
for how to address different types of
biological
challenges in the world of biological
data
a lot of things have been happening over
the years so you can see
in this next chart how the amount of
data
and the variety of data is really
changing
at a dramatic pace as a result many
biologists and clinicians are facing
this problem
of big data and how this data
comes in almost real time as we have
seen
in this pandemic almost every day there
are new
information there's new information
based on data
about genomic variation in the viral
genome we see different types of host
responses
patient responses and different animal
model responses to
how different treatments are applied or
different infections happen
in almost real time so we are really
seeing an influx of
a variety of different omics data types
what kinds of omic data types are there
there's
phenomics or characterization of cell
morphology
and tissue specificity and essentially
what are the external characteristics of
a sample
genomics which many of you are probably
familiar with or what is the
genomic variation or dna code variation
that we can study at the single
nucleotide level
or ranges of nucleotides or regions of
the dna
epigenomic variation how the condensed
chromatin inside the nucleus could be
expanded become more available
and ready for transcription and how
non-coding rnas
are guiding the process of gene
expression
and finally the gene expression itself
how can we understand
the expression of different transcripts
in the context of different conditions
and different samples that we observe
so the unique part of all of these omics
data sets is that they have to be
processed so essentially the data comes
in a form that we need to take
significant steps to modify from short
reads
into a table that could be analyzed and
this is true for genomics
epigenomics transcriptomics and
proteomics or metabolomics so many
different types of omics
ultimately however this whole field
of omics data and bioinformatics
is becoming more and more focused on the
challenges
of integration so
multiple factors that cause disease
and lead to disease progression lead us
to the to the onyx
integration process so we need to look
at how
cellular factors microbiome the virum
and clinical and phenotypic data are all
speaking about the same
phenomena and so as a result we have
designed these onyx logic programs that
are focused on
individual types of omix data and
individual types of clinical and
phenotypic data
in the context of applications how can
they be applied to
infectious diseases how can they be
applied to oncology
how can they be applied to microbiome
etc
so how are these programs organized the
way we conduct these programs
is by leveraging online tools like zoom
as we're doing today where we present a
specific topic
and have a discussion around the topics
related to this problem
self-guided study materials that help
you
understand a topic in greater detail and
learn about the different applications
from a theoretical point of view
as well as some practical assignments
and
interactive practice of what has been
learned
okay you could please
uh be mindful of people that are joining
so that when they join they could be
muted thank you
so when we have these practical
assignments and by the way we'll do a
couple of these today so those of you
that have already registered on the
introduction to bioinformatics course
you have probably been introduced to the
t bioinfo
platform here on top and we'll look
today at a couple of pipelines from the
t by info platform
and also the practical coding
assignments that come
on our omixlogic code playground so i'll
introduce those
in detail in a few more slides so how
can we
apply these different computational
tools
to data sets based on a specific topic
what we do in this program is we help
link
the different types of conditions that
are described
in projects and publicly available data
sets
to the type of data and the methods
that come with that data for example
we'll talk today
about three different types of resources
that we will leverage
in the course the courses on edu t
bioinfo
portal the platform and
the coding challenge on the coding
platform
so let's take a look at one example
one obvious example that most of you
were most interested in
is genomics right so how can we take dna
variation
that describes a condition like cancer
so these have to be somatic mutations
and process that data so that it could
be used
for analysis and understanding of that
biological condition
so what i'll do now is i'll go over to
the browser
and i will look at the browser
for what we have in one of our courses
called
genomics one
and in this course genomics one there is
an introduction
to somatic mutations okay so if
all of you are already locked in and
registered
on this portal you will see here under
courses
one okay so
please let me know when you are there by
putting number one
in the chat box so that i know that most
of you have found this resource called
genomics one
okay so i see that deborah at the tio
okay anyone else has found this resource
and maybe
uh we should post here the link
okay so this is the link to this
resource please let me know once you
have found it and it has loaded let's
take a look
at what is covered in this course so it
starts with
what is genomics and leads on to talk
about the biology of the genome
and define what is genomic variation
and in lecture 2.2 you are introduced
to a pipeline and this pipeline allows
you to
link together multiple scripts that will
transform
raw data from a sequencer into some kind
of a
defined genomic variation study
so let's take a look at what that will
be like by going to
server dot t dash file dot info
okay so now we're looking at two things
at the same time okay we're looking at
the course that introduces you to
genomics
and from that course you are introduced
to a bioinformatics analysis pipeline
which is on server dot t dash bio dot
info
okay so how many of you have now been
able to see this
pipeline
please put one in the chat box so i know
that you've
gotten there
okay and beeps if you could please post
the
demo information on how people that
don't have an account can join
and see the demo pipelines
okay so now we have the username and the
password
if you want to try this out and see how
it works
you can go right here
log in and once you're in
you'll be able to view some demo
pipelines that will illustrate
how to use this pipeline
okay so what i'll do is i'll show you a
couple of examples today
so you can see that this whole section
belongs to next generation sequencing
data next generation sequencing data
means that it was data generated
by a sequencer that produces short reads
and those short reads could now be
analyzed for variation by
mapping them onto the reference genome
so let's see how this works
right here if you scroll down we will
get to genomics epigenetics
and here we have a section called
mutation variance parallel analysis of
mutation variant data
this is the pipeline that is used
in genomics one so here we can click
on start you will see that we are
analyzing
variation at the single nucleotide level
and we can pre-process and map
this data we're not going to pre-process
for now
we're just going to go to bow tie 2
which is a mapping technique
and after mapping we will go to
visualization so visualization will
allow us to see
what do those short reads look like
when they are mapped onto the reference
genome
okay so after i have completed this
pipeline i've prepared the simple
pipeline of several steps
i will be able to click on visualization
and visualization will show me how those
individual reads
are mapped onto my reference sequence or
the reference genome
so you will notice that i have here two
samples
uh and these samples are going to be
displayed
over here the reads from those samples
and you can see that it says too much
data to show
indeed this is a big data analysis
so there's a lot of reads in each one of
these
and as i zoom in i am starting to see
how the individual reads are mapped to
the reference genome
so as i look in and i keep on zooming in
eventually
the individual nucleotides
on the reference genome and the reads
that show me the coverage
of what i have coming from these two
samples right so here i have
group one and then i have group two
now these are two samples
that represent a uh
a cancer camp essentially if you think
of
a patient that has a tumor
for that individual patient what we need
to know
is that patients tumor genome and that
patient's
general healthy genome and by comparing
the two
we can separate the germline mutations
from the somatic mutations and that's
exactly what you will see
as you do this pipeline and this
analysis so
the platform really allows you to
explore
huge data sets again this is whole exome
sequencing
of a cancer patient and by comparing
those genomes we can find somatic
variation
or specific genomes that are responsible
genomic variations that might be
responsible
for tumor differences from the healthy
genome
okay so i see that there's a raised hand
uh but i would ask that you instead
instead of uh raising the hand if you
have a
question please type it into the chat
and we will be looking at those
questions in the chat
in just a few minutes so that we can
help
answer any questions that you might have
okay so if you have any questions about
this pipeline or about genomic data
please go ahead and put those questions
in the chat box
and we will go through those questions
in just a second
so what did we see in this example what
we saw in this example
is how we can take a genomic
data set from a whole exome sequencing
and process it through this pipeline to
get
an understanding a visual representation
of read alignment to the reference
genome now how many of you know
how many nucleotides there are in the
human dna
how many people remember how many
nucleotides
are there in the human genome
all right thank you jioboli is saying
three billion base pairs
anybody else
okay 3.3 million or billion
30 000 billion
okay so there are some maybe uh
different opinions about how long it is
so most of you are correct it's about
3.2 billion
is the actual number so 3.2 billion
so it's a huge huge sequence right
and what we are doing here is we are
aligning
short reads that come from the sequencer
to the reference genome so how long do
you think
are sequencing read is when it comes
from
the sequencer does anyone know
the length of a typical sequencing read
okay for those of you that are just
joining we're discussing
genomic data and how sequencing can help
us study genomic variation
and we just went through an example of a
pipeline that helps us
process data that comes out from the
sequencer
in terms of genomic variation from the
reference genome
so the question is how long is a typical
read
okay 100 base pairs somebody is saying
maybe 60
i don't know seconds but maybe 60 base
pairs okay so the answer is
it could be anywhere between 30 and 350
base pairs okay that is
the next generation or the second
generation sequencing technology between
30 and 350 base pairs long
so as you can imagine using that kind of
sequencing technology
you end up with millions and millions of
reads
that are aligned to a super long
sequence of the whole reference genome
and so computationally this is a very
intense process
that requires what's called high
throughput computational analysis
technology so it's a parallelized
analysis
of many of these sequences and follows a
complicated process that will allow us
to understand
where do those reads fall onto the
reference genome
and how to find significant mutations
okay so here we have
a series of courses introduction to
genomics genomics 1
and genomics 2 that cover a lot of these
topics they cover the topic of how is
this data prepared
how does the mapping happen how do you
prepare your own pipeline
and how to make sense of what you get
out of this pipeline
another type of topics that we discussed
in our last session and many of you
showed an interest in
was transcriptomic data analysis or gene
expression how can we use the same
technology
to understand variation at the gene
expression level
so here you can see another pipeline
that looks somewhat similar
again it's a series of scripts that are
connected together
and what they produce is what's called a
table of expressions
the table of expression is a process
where we take individual reads and
count how many reads we have for each
one of our genes
to understand variability between
samples as you can see in this principal
component analysis
that maybe is described through the gene
expression levels
okay so here you will go through
another series of courses okay let's
take a look at these courses
uh let's take a look at what we have
for gene expression data
so again please go with me to the edu
t-bag for portal okay and on this portal
if you go to courses you can go to
transcriptomics one this is another
course just like we look right now at
genomics one
okay we can look at transcriptomics one
an introductory course
for transcriptomics thank you uh beeps
so in this course you will find a whole
set of introductory materials
gene expression what is transcription
how to quantify and understand
portions of dna that are being expressed
how can we then generate next generation
sequencing data and
also will provide you to a pipeline so
here you will see
how to develop a an
rna-seq study okay so the rna-seq
analysis pipeline we can look at it
again as a demo and beep say if you
could again
post the demo details in the chat box so
people could
look at those okay those that are
joining
just now we're providing you with just
the demo details so that you can try to
analyze the data as we go through this
example
thank you beeps okay so here again
we have a section on next generation
sequencing data
the next generation sequencing data can
be used to study genomics like
we just looked over here or can be used
to study
transcriptomics or rna-seq how we can
measure and
quantify gene expression levels again to
look at this from a demo perspective we
can take
the same data
and build a pipeline that allows us to
study
variation at the gene expression level
so again we can click on start
we will do some pre-processing by
trimming our reads from all kinds of
technical sequences
analyzing variation as a result of pcr
bridge amplification and removing those
and then we can map our gene expression
data or our
sequences of reads we can click
on to t and prepare
an r sem table of
expression okay and this is what the
table of expression will look like
so once we put this together this is
again a
pipeline this pipeline
will show the following results these
results will include
the table of expression and
that table of expression could be in
different formats it could have
expression of genes expression of
isoforms
expression of exons
so once you see this type of data you
will realize
that it has a lot of information how
many of you remember how many genes
there are
in the human genome
okay so if you know the answer you can
put it in the chat box
how many genes are there in the human
genome approximately
okay does anyone remember how many jeans
okay thank you a volley
about twenty thousand tufiq is saying
about
five thousand okay anyone else
at the time is saying 30 000.
okay so indeed the right answer is about
25 000 genes
okay so 25 000 genes
in your typical human genome
now that number is approximate why
because
the definition of a gene is a sequence
that produces a mature mrna that will be
translated to protein
so when we talk about genes that
definition
and finding those sequences has been
changing over the period of time
as you know the human genome was uh
fully sequenced about
50 years ago but for the past 50 years
that information has been going on and
we know now a lot more about genes and
about their
function than we did back 50 years ago
so this is
a dynamic field where a lot of changes
are happening
so if you open this table this is a
table of samples used
to produce the table of expression you
can see that this is
breast cancer genes or breast cancer
samples
of different subtypes and so when we
will expect our table of expression we
will actually have
50 58 uh
samples and those 58 samples
are going to be of different types of
cell lines
so the process of now downstream
analysis
of the data that we produced in this
pipeline is going to be
again explained in our
uh online coursework okay and so
let's take a look at what type of
coursework do we have for transcriptomic
data
so that all of you can gain insight into
what to do with this table of expression
transcriptomics one will discuss the
process of
analyzing the individual reads and
transforming them into a table of
expression how to explore the table of
expression
transcriptomics 2 will talk about
statistical analysis
of differences between groups of samples
transcript dynamics 3 will introduce you
to machine learning
and transcriptomics 4 will show you how
to use this for
single cell transcriptomic data
okay again if you have any questions
about transcriptomic data analysis
you can put that in the chat box and
we'll be
coming to your questions in just a few
minutes
another type of data that a lot of you
have shown interest in
is metagenomics metagenomics can help us
study
the microbiome or the complex community
of microbes that have that lives
together in a single sample
to understand differences between sample
groups
based on species diversity and richness
and this is an amazing change in the way
microbes
can be studied first of all microbes
were first detected
as a result of looking through the
microscope and as the resolution of the
microscope has increased
we now know that these are complex
complex communities you can see here an
example from
a very high resolution microscopic image
that shows how individual e coli
bacteria
are being attacked by phages and you can
see the individual phages right here
so what people have now just
understood is that this is not just
a single organism that lives in
isolation but this is an interacting
community
of different microbes that live together
and work together to produce what we
call a phenotype whether it's a
condition or a disease
and so from the isolation techniques in
the lab
today we can single we can look at a
single bacteria
or we can start studying these bacterias
as a microbiome as communities that
function
and live together to produce some kind
of an environment
that could be associated with a
condition and so when we talk about the
microbiome
there are a growing number of papers
that are being published
on the microbiome including the lung
vagina brain skin liver and other types
of mouth and intestinal microbiomes
there are literally tens of thousands of
publications
on the way microbiome could characterize
different diseases
and so we can look at these ongoing
projects and studies to understand how
to analyze such
data from publicly available
repositories to
study disease of the gut sensitivity
different types of skin conditions lung
conditions
even brain conditions so a lot of
different data sets are available out
there
so again if you have any questions about
the microbiome
you're welcome to post those questions
in the
chat so that by the end of this
presentation we'll be addressing
many of your questions another important
part of this training that we're going
to be doing in the upcoming program
is how to analyze these large data sets
once they are processed and structured
so we will look at a number of different
examples of
genomic data transcriptomic data
metagenomic data
each one will come in a structured
format it will be a table
and we'll look at different applications
of machine learning
and statistical analysis methods to
understand
how we can extract meaningful insights
and for that purpose
it's important to have some introduction
to
coding skills in r and python
and so maybe somebody at the taiyo or
beep so you guys can post the link to
the coding
platform on the coding platform we have
practical exercises for those of you
that are ready to
analyze such data using our packages
and python approaches where you can
learn about things like principal
component analysis different
visualization techniques
classification clustering etc so you can
really
take a look at that and again you can
sign up for free
as we will go through this program we
will leverage some of those exercises
in our upcoming sessions
so all that we cover today is
a good overview of what we will in
detail
study throughout the whole program
that will include a number of different
sessions
that will focus on one particular topic
and give you a lot more time to go
through
understanding from very beginning up
until you know
how to apply this information to a
particular data set
so going through this training will give
you the tools
and the conceptual understanding to
start using omix data
and bioinformatics so this will include
a session on an introduction to next
generation sequencing we'll talk about
the different
file formats and the links and the
different specific details about this
data format
we'll talk about bioinformatics in
application to big data and biomedical
research
we'll also talk about how we can
leverage the asynchronous courses in
greater detail but
it's not just about the asynchronous
courses you also gain access to mentors
that can support and answer specific
questions you have
and then we'll go through individual
types of data
and do a little bit of practice together
to understand how
to use those data sets effectively now
as as we go through this program
you will see that your activity and
everybody's activity
that is participating in this program is
going to be tracked
and the reason for that is we want to
find
a most effective way to combine
the practical exercises on the platform
and on the coding
uh playground with the asynchronous
theoretical
courses so that everyone can start
working on
independent projects so these
independent projects
will allow you to apply what you have
learned
through a data set that has a
description of whatever
that project was and you will see how
after you have completed
the basic training you will gain access
to practical examples that are sourced
from
peer-reviewed journal data sets
that have been published in association
with
a real challenge so we'll look at such
examples
as ebola virus outbreak in west africa
and the origins and pathogenesis of the
novel coronavirus
so case examples case studies and
examples
that are very relevant and current with
what we
are experiencing as uh as citizens
and also as people interested in
biomedical research
now we have done this program with
thousands of students
we encourage all of you to sign up but
just to give you a perspective
on how this program has benefited other
people
in nigeria that are going to be helping
you go through this program
i wanted to introduce you to our
omixlogic nigeria team uh which includes
adekunle adelu he is a an omixlogic
nigeria project lead and he's a faculty
at leeds city university at the tayo
aborigi
he is also faculty at bayero
university in nigeria and sunny hamza he
is a medical laboratory scientist
at the university of lagos nigeria so
adekunle i would like to pass it on to
you now
please can you hear me
okay as adekunle is joining us
i want to just briefly take a look at
the questions that you posted in the
chat box
um i see that some people were asking
for
the video recording so i'm sure that
beeps is going to share that on our
youtube channel
and then i see um i
see okay
[Music]
one second okay
so elia there's this question by farida
bashir
can you hear me yes i can oh our
question is
can a pcr machine serve a function as
the next sequencer
why you want to perform gene analysis of
a particular disease
well pcr machine
is a process of generating
sequences of a particular
kind of determine type right so for
example you can have a primer
and that primer amplifies rna or dna
in your sample so that way you can study
specific types of sequences to identify
whether they are present and if they are
present if they have some
variation so it's a good way to find
mutations it's a good way to analyze
specific types of sequences
next generation sequencing is different
from pcr itself
it does not just amplify the
genetic material it actually allows us
to study
all of the genetic material in a sample
and
quantify it including looking at
specific
variants like mutation variants
so i'm not sure that i have answered
that completely but
i will take a look again at all of these
questions towards the end of the
session and in the meantime adequately
can you hear us
yes please i can hear you okay great so
i'll pass it on to you then
all right thank you very much um earlier
all right um as mentioned my name is adi
kulia dilway i'm a faculty from
leeds city university nigeria and i'm
also a mentor with
prime biotech i have my background in
medical laboratory sciences and
my area of focus currently is molecular
biology and genomics
we are currently completing a phd degree
so um as a lecturer i'm involved with
lecturing body medical scientists nurses
and radiographers
all of which are taking courses in the
biological sciences
and i can say authoritatively that many
of our curriculum is designed around the
theoretical components of this
course of studies and has less to do
about the analysis and utilization of
biological data
that is being generated in our clinical
laboratory settings
as many of us know already um the volume
of this data set has increased
significantly
in this era of genomics and omic
science and um like i did mention last
time
as exciting as bioinformatic ease
and bioinformatics cities the fact is
there are computational resources gap
when it comes to successful running of
these bioinformatics pipeline
these like we said includes
infrastructure requirements
of course the cost and we also have
inaccessibility issues but more
importantly which is one area i'd like
to focus on
this evening is the expertise gaps
our teachings in its present framework
within our universities
does not teach required data science or
bioinformatics skills
which and you know skill sets that is
needed by our students to adequately
analyze this data
and to make insightful um discovery from
them
and this is where personally i find very
interesting and helpful the pinebartex
and cloud-based
artificial intelligence guided server
for participants
to utilize in their learning journey
aside the web structured in synchronous
courses which we've been introduced to
by elia
and other learning resources that are
you know loaded
um on the websites um the learners can
immediately
begin to have hands-on experience on big
data analysis
and so by that i mean you know as you
are learning you are having opportunity
to practice what you are learning
using you know the available resources
especially the tbr server
you know that is um being provided by
um by pine biotech here on this slide is
a screenshot from one of my own personal
project
pipelines which i run using the
cloud-based ai guided
t-server platform and it will interest
you know many of our parts fans to know
that i um you know
got involved i mean i came across prime
belt tech
sometimes last year and you can imagine
the
you know what i've been able to learn
using the
platform within this short um span of
time
okay so i want to emphatically say
fine biotech platform the edutip power
um
info platform as well as it is um tipo
server platform are two platforms that
will help
each and every one of us to learn
bioinformatics
and big data science and as well as
apply these learnings as we go you know
on in our learning journey
so i i therefore look forward to having
many
you know more professionals university
faculties and lecturers
researchers you know as well as students
as boarding
professionals professionals you know in
the making to come up and key into the
opportunity that is available by
participating
you know in the program that is
forthcoming the basic
omis logic and training part one of
course um
like um um our facilitator
elia spoke about there are a series of
programs that have to come after the
physical mixed logic training part one
okay but sequentially and
you know methodically we want to use
these programs to introduce participants
to these um
skill sets in the bioinformatics and big
data sciences
and to ensure that participants get to
learn this case
and able to utilize it in their own
personal
researches um quickly before i handle um
over to the next
speaker i like to mention from our last
session some of the questions we have
you know that people were asking has to
do with asking
the possibility of applying what we are
here learning or talking about
in their own personal you know studies
in their own personal feed we have um
people talking
you know that they are in the
eco-tourism and wildlife um
you know feed some are from animal
technology why some are you know equally
clinicians and
pharmaceutical microbiologists so i like
to say that
you know learning this case apparently
you know
we go a long way in enhancing our
researches
and the way you know we utilize the data
sets that are being generated in a
laboratory
and um quickly um another thing i'd like
to add
um which i know km came up in the
last webinar we had was trying um you
know some people asking about
um possibility of making this
training the main training which will be
starting um next
week tuesday that is on the 19th of
january making it
you know cheaper as it were and um
well thankfully the the
you know earlier the you know mentioned
last week
that there's an opportunity for
scholarship for some of us who might be
having challenges to
you know make the payments for this
training
how big i like to mention that these
same trainings in other climbs
in europe in america costs um you know
about 850 dollars
okay and um we've been able to you know
discuss and you know prevail on the
leadership of prime biotech to
make these um costs you know offer it to
nigerians at
25 which is equivalent of about you know
10 000
about of course um i'd like to assure
all the
participants who will be coming on board
that um we're
going to be getting much much more than
the value we are
you know putting in the last thing i'd
like to talk about
before i hand over would be the access
to the you know resource materials yes
we have a number of free resources on
this platform
you know introduction to bioinformatics
which we expect all our registered um
registered participant as well as just
everyone
on these webinar to you know register a
profile and
you know try to run through these
courses
but outside of that um people who go on
to register for this training program
that is
coming we have access you know to the
server um that we've been talking about
the server platform
with which they will have the hands-on
experience and of course the mentor
and the you know support that will be
needed to
learn and you know practice what he's
been learning on the go
so um on that note i will want to hand
over but
encourage as many of the participants
who still have one or two questions to
please not hesitate to ask their
questions so that we can
answer each and every one um
at this point let me pass it over to um
dr borussia day to take it
up from there thank you mr um
i think for me as a clinician and as
someone that is
interested in research especially in our
clients where resources are limited
the first question that i asked myself
when i wanted to come into
bioinformatics is the cost
can i afford sequencing can i afford
net generation sequencing can i afford
to do all these
research items by myself from the
scratch
and i think that's one of the questions
elia already answered
as researchers we really do not need to
start most of these studies have been
issued
there are studies that have been done
sequence sequences
that have been placed in repositories
public databases that as a researcher
you just need to know how to retrieve
this information from these databases
and be on just start your analysis
analysis from that start that's also one
of the advantages of this training
program
that's one of the advantages of this
platform that you can be guided
by the facilitator fundamentals on how
to retrieve
information from public databases from
for example could be genomic sequences
it could be transmit consequences
how you can retrieve them in your field
in your area
with inverting area you can receive
subsequent genomic sequences of
consequences of your of your research
animals like dogs like cats and the only
thing that you just
do as a researcher is just to analyze
them and be able to exact
the same questions you would have asked
if you had
if you are if you are sequencing them
issues that's also one of the advantages
of this training program
another advantage is he has no verbal
formations
there is a dirt of mentorship especially
here
due to the expertise gaps one of the
problems i had when i started
was i needed mentors to guide me
as we got projectors and research items
which i did not have at those times it
discouraged me for a while and it
nearly killed the law for bioinformatics
but that's one of the advantages
by baltic also has that both locally and
internationally
you can speak with the faculty in
nigeria you can also speak with the
faculty
in u.s and india and each and every one
of them will be eager to be available
and they are approachable to assist with
whatever research item
or research tools you need at that point
in time another thing which i also found
that made it easier to learn with
bioinformatics
is that you do not need to be
a connoisseur in data science it's not
only to be
an experienced bioinformatician or a
machine learning
person before you can make use of the
pipeline
if you can follow the steps written out
in the synchronous courses
and decoding platforms you can as well
code you can as well practice
like a vector formation because they are
well spread out they are written out in
a b and c's
in one two and three giving you
the desired outcome for each data or
which attitude you have
these are many more are the advantages
of these programs
and the the reason we also feel that
assigns the
faculty to us in india now we also
require a faculty in nigeria
because we can so that at every point in
time
you can easily put a call true to any
mentor you can easily put a country
training faculty
in case you need queries questions and
guidance and mentorship as regards any
of these pipelines and that's why we
feel that this program
is well equipped to answer and cater for
every of your research items
every of your research questions every
of your
curiosity as regards bioinformatics so
that by the end of this training program
we can have
a full established faculty
in bioinformatics and data science
thank you very much i'll warn you watch
early at this point
okay so thank you very much uh
and again the team in nigeria
is going to be supporting a lot of your
questions and technical issues but
i want to answer some of the questions
that have been posted
um taiwo uh has asked
about his research problem how can this
training aid
and promote my research and other people
have
specific questions about their projects
and their data sets and so
as you have seen we've taken a few
examples
of published data that is on ncbi
translated those into project examples
and a lot of
our participants in previous programs
have been able to use that as a
springboard
into the world of omics data and
bioinformatics and i want to give you
just a couple more examples
so here is dr ayurende fayahun who is
also a physician
and is doing his masters in
bioinformatics at university of ibanan
in nigeria
and after completing the training that
he you can see right here the
certificates that he received from the
training program
he developed his own interest in
infectious diseases found a data set on
ncbi
under the guidance of our team and was
able to perform
a differential gene expression analysis
to identify genes
responsible for response to infection or
the immune response to infection
another participant of one of our
previous programs
kuda kwashiya nayombo who is a
researcher and has a masters of science
and technology from university of
zimbabwe in harare
uh was looking at in-depth
transcriptomic analysis to determine the
response to inhibition of pkna gene and
pknb
gene by tuberculosis so
as you can see for any of you interested
in a particular domain
the limiting factor for you to be able
to apply bioinformatics to a research
project of your own
is not the tools and it's not the
understanding of the technology it's
actually just
availability of data so before we
continue to speak about
all of uh the rest of this presentation
i wanted to take you to a source of data
that you can find on ncbi
so please come to this website this is
the national center for biotechnology
information
a website dedicated to
[Music]
different types of data and after you
finish after you get to this website
please let me know by putting in number
one into the chat box
okay so please go to ncbi.nlm.nih.gov
again you should see something very
similar to what i have right here on
my screen and thank you deborah for
putting in number one so that means that
you are there
so briefly about ncbi the national
center for biotechnology information
is a is a collection
of different types of resources you can
see
different resources right here they
include
data and software different types of
software
and different types of structures and
data sets
okay all right so i see honor is also
here
okay so for those of you that are here
you can see that we can search
in here for any topic that you would
like so would anyone like
to propose a topic that you're
interested in
what kind of an experiment would you be
interested to
look at to understand if they have data
about that experiment
okay so you can just put that example
into the chat box again for those of you
that are already here
okay any topic that comes to mind any
topic that you're currently researching
we'll just want to see whether they have
this type of data
on ncbi already
okay hepatitis and hamza was saying
hepatitis
uh farida is saying serene protease of
snake venom
okay anyone else let's do just a third
one
so if anyone else has an idea
okay diabetes sickle cell
uh sickle cell anemia
antimicrobial peptides cancer genomics
okay so let's take a look at these
examples one by one so the first one was
hepatitis
okay and i do want to mention that the
program is designed in such a way to
introduce you
to the different types of omics data
sets introduce you to different project
examples that we have prepared
and allow you to work on an independent
project of your own
for those that complete all of this
training we will provide
a certificate of excellence and a
platform for you to speak about
your project to an audience that is
probably
beyond your reach right now an
international audience that will listen
to your project
example and so these milestones that you
will achieve throughout the program
the basic training the introductory
materials
for projects and a project of your own
each come with a specific certificate
overall turning it
into a certificate of excellence
and a certificate of
completion of these courses will be
given to each one that completes the
basic training
okay so here we see the results for
hepatitis now obviously
there are many different types of
hepatitis hip that is c and b
in different animals etc but you can see
this is
gene expression omnibus data sets so how
many data sets exist
using transcriptomic data over nine
thousand you can see right here raw data
sequence read archive so it just reads
from the sequencer
over 12 000 bio projects
over 700 bio projects so these are
collections of data sets okay so
a huge amount of data let's take a look
at another one
someone mentioned snake venom
okay so let's put this snake venom
again geo data sets over 20
geo data sets uh over 30 sra
read archives let's just take a look at
some of these examples what can we find
here
you can customize your search and we'll
go through this in
much greater detail when we do our uh
program but just quickly for the purpose
of today
i'm going to change this to expression
profiling by high throughput sequencing
okay and now i can click on this filter
and let's see so here's a gene
expression data set
the neuromuscular junction is a focal
point of
mtor c1 signaling in sarcopenia
okay and this was uh you can read here a
little bit
more about this abstract
okay so uh not sure
that this is directly related let's see
over here rna sequencing of venom glands
and venom blend organoids
okay i think very interesting
what else do we have here okay so you
can see that we have quite a number of
results
for snake venom sickle cell
anemia so such common conditions like
sickle cell anemia hepatitis is probably
going to be a lot
okay here you can see um 579
items for sickle cell anemia um
so single cell transcriptomic profiling
provides insight into maturational and
developmental status of pluripotent stem
cell-derived erythroblasts
um let's see um
transcriptional responses in children
with sickle cell so a lot of different
examples exist for a variety of topics
and i think that you know importantly we
are
all now captured at home sitting
waiting for us to understand what can we
personally do
in this era of this pandemic of the rise
in infectious diseases how can we apply
bioinformatics
and publicly available tools as well as
data sets
to make a difference to make an impact
on what's going on right now
and i think that er exciting part of
what we are doing here
is not just learning for the purpose of
gaining certificates right
we want those that complete this
training to be
citizen scientists people that can
contribute solutions
and new ways of analyzing data to
understand what's going on around us
so let's take a look at an example
from another resource from ncbi
called ncbi virus okay so
ncbi virus
is a repository of data sets
specifically about infectious diseases
okay
so in this repository and i'll just put
the link
over here you can find uh
a whole collection of resources
dedicated to
communicable or infectious diseases
okay so for example let's search by
virus
and we'll put in here sars cove 2
okay so you can see i put in sars and
it's going to open up
a drop down and you can see the first
one is severe acute respiratory syndrome
coronavirus
ii so i can click on this to see
all of the associated resources
and you can see that there are over 48
000 nucleotide sequences available to
study
related to source code 2. they are
organized here by type of virus
you can see the sequence length and type
you can see nucleotide completeness
and you can also see in which coast and
which geographic region
including over 400 in africa okay so
over 400
sequences for sars growth ii in africa
so i think
in this program you will realize how
learning about the tools and about these
kinds of repositories really opens the
door
for you to start thinking about an
independent project
that could be very relevant if you're
involved in any kind of biomedical
research
to make a difference and not only learn
about uh you know this for your own good
so again we have a lot of examples of
people that have
successfully completed also have
gone on to receive certificates of
completion for the full program and
develop
for example you can see here the
research project developed by kingston
in starscope 2 evolution spiked gene
mutations across
geographical regions in africa so i
think i will
say that's exactly sorry
the type of uh question that you were
asking
okay so research projects right i think
what's important here
is that you will gain access to training
and tools and then introduction to a
number of different projects
that you can try to apply these tools in
a guided way
so for those of you that have already
signed up on the platform
you need to now just join the course
that we are
discussing in this webinar for those of
you that have not signed up
what you need to do is you need to
register
now okay so let me show you again
how to do that let's go back
to this website okay so please let me
know
for those of you that have not
registered
you need to be able to see on the main
website
a login button okay so right here
if i am already registered i will see my
name
if i am not registered i will see a
login button
so if you have already created an
account and please complete your
individual profile with your full name
because that will go in your certificate
and an avatar or your picture because
that will help us understand who we are
dealing with
and others to see that you're a real
person
once you get there right here under
events in the main menu
you will find different programs that
are available and the one we are
discussing this webinar
is this one for nigeria basic training
so you can click
on this button and you will be
redirected to the organization
page for those that will participate in
this program
okay so what does this organization page
include
it includes a forum where you can post
any of your questions
or any of your challenges technical
challenges
courses that are included in this
program that will include
genomics transcriptomics and
metagenomics
projects like ebola virus and source
growth 2
and others that you can start exploring
a full syllabus
of the program assignments that you will
be graded on
and will help you understand how much
you are able to do
with the types of tools that we are
doing and a few other things so all of
your activity will end up
being listed over here and you will be
able to interact with the other
participants and
we have hundreds and thousands of users
that have completed this training
and we want to organize a community
out of this training because it's
important that when you're in
bioinformatics you can interact with
others that can think of
new problems new challenges new data
sets and applications
to real problems right so what we have
is a community
on facebook we have a facebook group
called learning biomedical informatics
and we also have a linkedin group so
you will see that joining this website
is an introduction to a community
not just the training and you will see
that in these communities we also
highlight
the profiles of those that do
exceptionally well
in the programs develop impactful
projects and that helps you
form collaborations maybe even get
admitted to a lab a research lab or
find different opportunities for
employment and building out your career
so we hope that you can leverage this
as a part of this training as well what
we will help you do
is understand the specific topics
develop a project
and also present this project in an
impactful way
to your peers for peer review in the
program
potentially also going on to publish in
a pro
in a a separate program
those of you that are just interested
and you are still considering
signing up we have a number of
opportunities to join different types of
programs and for those of you that
already have the training you're already
a bioinformatician
you're already you know good at
doing the analysis part if you would
like to
work on a project of your own we have
a special research fellowship a program
that is designed to help you develop a
project and this could be
a three month or a six month program in
that program
you will work with a mentor to go
through
the important uh parts of literature
review
planning your analysis and preparing
your presentation so that you have an
impactful project at the end
again we welcome you to join the program
uh this program is going to start um
beeps and maybe you could share some of
the practical uh details on how to sign
up
and when everything will get started
right
if i may share my screen i do have uh
certain things to show everyone
thank you
yeah so as you all know that we are
starting the program
on january 19th so
this is the landing page i'm sure that
most of you must have registered as
you're joining today's webinar but in
case
you have not i've put the link in the
chat box
and i will put it down again so this is
the
first step to get started
by registering and once you do you will
receive an
email from africa at pine dot bio in
case you want to reach out to africa at
find out bio you can also email the team
right there
and once you're registered for the
program
you have access to this organization
page that elia has been showing you
now i did explain this in our last
meeting so today i wanted to talk about
what should you do
once you are registered for the program
you have made your payment
and you have received all the info the
first step that you should do is update
your profile
now i'm going to be showing you two
examples of different profiles
now here i'm taking this profile as an
example so i see that kehinde has
full name written down completed meta
genomics 2 and has earned 600 points but
however the profile is incomplete and on
the other hand
uh ronald here has a complete profile
where you can
clearly see that this is a person
and you can identify ronald from this
profile and see that
completed all these courses and the
reason
completing your profile is very
important is because
as a community we can then reach out to
each other because this is a scientific
community and we believe in
collaboration and i'm sure that when
you're part of this
program you will be collaborating not
only with
us but also with each other and learn
more about the other participants were
there
and we also have a special feature
called the leaderboard
so if you earn enough points right now
you see that there are a lot of
participants up here on the leaderboard
who has been part of our previous
programs and has earned a lot of points
and each of these participants have a
completed profile so you can actually
relate to these different participants
and that is the utility
of completing your profile and going
ahead
you can also add your social media links
there's an option to add your social
media links and for researchers you can
add your orcid ids
so that it's more easier for other
people to find you in case
in the future you may would want to
complete all the courses
share this link directly with
somebody who would be interested in
learning more about you and your
achievements
so that is one of the reasons why you
should have your profile complete
now once you have the profile completed
and you're ready to begin and we still
have some time before the program starts
on january 19th
here are the coursework so all
participants who are registered will
have
a link to this page
and this is part of the organization
page and elia has already explained this
and we went through some of these
courses here so
i saw that a lot of the participants
from last time have
started with introduction to
bioinformatics but i only saw that
godspar oberli has been able to
complete introduction to bioinformatics
and if you have already completed
introduction to bioinformatics you can
start with the other free course which
is introduction to genomics
but just before the program begins this
would be good that
most of us can complete introduction to
bioinformatics and have an
idea about what we are going to learn
in this upcoming program and this basic
bind for matrix training
is what we call level one
program where we introduce
uh participants who are just starting to
learn about bioinformatics
to this different concepts to
multi-omics
and help them learn so that they can
reach
level two yeah so they can reach
uh level two so what is level two when
they do a more advanced
program and design their own research
project
so this is step one learning from the
courses today as i saw that
there are a lot of questions uh from our
participants
whether this course work is going to be
relevant
to their research or not so
that is where the coursework is uh going
to be very self-explanatory along with
those sessions and this will give you an
overview
which in the future will help you
develop your own project so this is a
very step-by-step process that is why we
start from the very basic
introduction to bioinformatics so that
we can build up
uh from step one to step two and
above and beyond right and once
you are done with the course work
through this program
we will introduce you to project so elia
already mentioned
the ebola project and there are other
projects as well
which are available so once you finish
all the coursework
that would be the next step which is
doing one of the projects which are here
or you can also propose your own project
now i would want to talk uh right now
a little bit about the scholarship
process
so we have received uh the applications
for the scholarship
and i just wanted to let you all know
that it was being processed
and the first step of the process is
whenever you write down any of your
references
we would want to set up a meeting with
your references
introduce them uh to what we are doing
here
and also learn more about you so that we
can understand whether
you are fit for the scholarship usually
this scholarship is granted
to undergraduate students but
in case there are any special
circumstances that is the reason for the
meeting
so we are reaching out to you from
africa at pine.bio
uh regarding all of your submissions
please allow us some time
and if you're mentioning uh your
references you can also let them know
that you're being part of a program
so that if we have time if we set up a
time for a meeting
you can then uh bring them and you know
we all can have
a discussion together regarding your
joining the program
and if you have any other questions then
please
put them down in the chat box and the
next thing again that i wanted to share
is what uh adi conley aditya
and elia has already been sharing which
is like doing your own project
so this starts in level two right once
you finish this program and you are
ready you
have learned about the different omics
topics you know
about the logic the application you move
on
to proposing your own project where you
see there are different
people who have already done their
project i have also
shared this link right now in the chat
box you can go ahead and take a look
and all of these are individual
presentation
so as elia was telling you that you will
not only be
doing your project but you will also be
presenting the project
where you will record a video like this
do a proper uh
presentation and we will be sharing the
video on your behalf in our youtube
channel which is watched by thousands
of subscribers we will share it in our
groups
as you have already seen uh the groups
that we have
in linkedin and
here is our linkedin group and also in
facebook
so once you are joining these groups and
being part
of the program you can see that
there is a lot of benefit you are not
only being part of
uh just this program but in the future
a part of a larger community who
interact with each other who shared
different uh you know research
publications with each other so you are
able to learn and connect
with an international community and
before i end today's
meeting and presentation i just wanted
to let you know
regarding those who had a question about
the tbio
info server so access to this server
is only created by us
so once you're registered for a program
you will receive an
email which will have the details to
login to tibia info server
and the username would usually be your
email id but we will create the password
for you
if you are not joining this program
but you still want to try out the demo
pipelines
you can actually request for access so
once you request for access you will
have this
form that you can fill up and once you
fill up the
form you will receive an email from my
end which is marketing at pine.bio
with the demo access to the platform and
also some details about the different
licenses that you can
uh purchase to take the uh
to utilize the platform so we do have
educational licenses
and research licenses the research
license
gives you full access to the platform
which means that
you are able to upload your own data
files and in case
uh you are only looking to learn we
would definitely recommend you to join
the program because
all of this is included within the
program the educational
access on the other hand if you're
purchasing it is 75
so if you are looking forward to utilize
this system
and learn from the system the best way
is to join the program start with the
basic program
and then move on to the more advanced
learning stage or the advanced project
stage
and now if you have any questions this
is open
so please let me know
either myself ilya or
aditya and the african team can answer
your questions
thank you biebs and i also wanted that
to mention at the tio i put the link to
the youtube
uh for you to have
um share with everyone in the chat and
i also will post the link to everyone
so everyone can see the recording of
this webinar
great thank you very much thank you
everyone for joining it was great to see
all of you again for those that are
already registered
and we look forward to seeing you soon
as the program starts
we also have some other resources that
we will be sharing with you and
hopefully you will join our
social media as well so we'll we'll stay
in touch there
and connect personally thank you
thank you elia and thank you everyone
for joining again today
the trainings each day would be at 4 30
p.m it's the same time
4 30 p.m w 80 so
we have tried to make it in the
afternoon so that it's easier for
everyone to join
thank you and if you have any further
questions please reach out to
africa at pile.bio for our team
there to help you with any of your
queries
and thank you everyone for joining again
it's a pleasure to meet everyone